hey guys i'm philip molina this is a
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 6
episode 4 book of the stranger and this
season is moving along very fast and
this episode is packed so I'm just gonna
jump right into the analysis and
theories let's start with the opening
images the opening shot shows us Jon
Snow's sword Longclaw and after walking
off and saying my watch has ended last
episode this image represents that fact
that jon is literally laying down his
arms now last episode I talked about the
Nights Watch oath and I think it's worth
pointing out that everyone said that jon
is safe because he died which would
clear him from his own and yeah I pretty
much agree with all of you but I think
it's very interesting that this episode
starts with that exact same debate about
whether or not that's technically true
because like Edie reminds us the oath
also says for all nights to come so
again I'm down with Jon saying yeah
that's that oath but also we gotta admit
it's not just simple black and white
he's got to choose to walk away from
that oath but let's just go ahead and
move on to the biggest emotional payoff
this episode maybe one of the biggest
ones of the series
John and Sansa's tear-jerking hug it's
the first of three brother-sister
reunions in this episode and after
waiting for a stark family reunion for
years I think
everyone watching was like holy crap
this is more emotion than I felt in
years like in my lucky according to my
Twitter poll this was your favorite
moment of the episode but it's
interesting that this is the one we get
considering John and Sansa have never
actually spoken to each other on this
show before I think one of the reasons
it still hits us so really hard is the
music really works something we rarely
hear is the full house stark theme and
that's what we're hearing here this
episode was actually the first to
feature the full playthroughs of several
major character scores including the
Stork Lannister and Targaryen themes but
I'm gonna mention those kind of as they
come
oh also real quick yeah torment is
totally i effing Brean as she rides past
them Lilly he wants to make a giant baby
with her that might be the stallion
that's the world something breeds
reaction that I love is just grabbing
her sword which is like a threat from
her but it's exactly like up his alley
probably makes him want her more I'll
get back to that haut-brion tormund
romance later so moving on to this sweet
brother-sister scene between John and
Sansa this whole interaction actually
really mirrors Ned and Catelyn in season
1 when Ned didn't want to go south to
fulfill his duty but Callan urged him
that it was the right thing to do now
stances become the duty driven badass
and she drinks beer now by the way and
she's saying she's gonna take back
Winterfell alone if she has to Sansa has
gone full Stark now she's even wearing
the stark wolf furs that we saw her
wearing maybe last only in like a season
one probably so imagine if I'd asked you
at the end of season one right after Ned
is beheaded hey which Starks do you
think are gonna become the badasses that
are gonna avenge the family name I don't
think you would've guessed it be the
dainty lady Sansa and Jon Snow who is
not a fully legitimate Stark and he's a
brother of the Nights Watch who's
supposed to completely stay out of the
politics of the realm pretty surprising
I just want to point out how this
episode has a lot of Sansa kind of
standing up for Jon Snow reminding
everyone that he's half Star
I feel like that's actually got to be a
little bit of this journey that John has
to go in the idea of him having to go
back and reclaim Winterfell it also
would mean that he has to newly and
finally claim himself as a start and so
I feel like that's maybe what Santa has
to be able to bring to her brother is a
reminder that he really is a start
whether or not he does end up getting
legitimized he just doesn't seem to
really believe that himself right now
but I feel like that is also an arc that
we need to see play out before he's
really ready to go take back Winterfell
now before I move on I want to point out
a shot that kept appearing in this scene
with Sansa and John both being boxed in
by the scenery in the very next scene we
find Davos and Melisandre framed the
exact same way if you think about it
these are all characters who we've
wondered what would happen if they were
actually finally put in a room together
and forced to deal with their [ __ ] Sansa
and Jon have been reunited for minutes
but now here they are boxed in together
having to face what has happened in
Winterfell it's kind of like a parent
putting two quarreling siblings in a
room until they figure out the problem
and then Davos and Melisandre they've
been pretty distracted lately what with
all the resurrecting but they haven't
had a chance to deal with what we've all
been wondering like shouldn't Davos be
all like hey what exactly happened with
Stannis and Shireen so here they are it
caved in together having to deal with
their drama into these tough questions
then we get a third instance of this a
second later when Bryan joins in because
as she reminds us she also has beef with
Melisandre since she played a huge part
in killing Renly so this framing device
it's meant to underline the fact that
there's nowhere to run anymore these
characters are finally being put
together and they have to deal with
their stuff that caged in framing
meaning that you've got nowhere to go
having to face what has happened it's
probably a cinematic reference to the
old fritz long film em where the
technique was maybe most famously used
to show how actions have led a character
to be metaphorically and visually trap
but moving on to the eerie finally we
see where Littlefinger has been
this season bird shopping no actually I
think there is a big clue in this moment
that's being dropped as to what
Littlefinger's really been up to but I'm
not ready to discuss that theory just
yet I will be in this video though so
don't worry just I'm gonna ask you to
please remember this moment I know come
and see
I missed your nameday go on now as for
the gift he has for Robin the Falcon is
part of the sigil for the house Aaron
and you see it on all their banners you
can't even see it in Robins cloak the
kid loves Falcons and it's actually one
of the many callbacks to other times
we've had in the past on the show this
episode is just full of these kinds of
callbacks you remember back in season 4
little finger returned to the Eyrie
bearing a gift for Robin and that time -
it was a falcon though that one was made
of crystal and Robin immediately dropped
it out the moon door he's such a little
dick also worth noting when Littlefinger
calls him the defender of the Vale it's
immediately followed by a really long
shot of Robin dropping his bow and arrow
which is another instance of laying down
your arms but in this case it's just
ironic because yeah defender of the Vale
this sickly kid is not and that's even
considering that somehow he grew like
three feet taller since the last time
Littlefinger saw him he's definitely
being made fun of by cuffing him
defender of the Vale oh and I quickly
want to point out here what is going on
when Littlefinger turns the tables on
Lord Royce with this story about getting
captured by the Bolton's now this is a
complete lie he willingly went to the
Bolton and gave them Sansa but this is
one of those stories that Littlefinger
loves to tell to manipulate the
situation and get his way I will come
back to this idea of telling stories to
get your way but let's note this is a
huge win for Littlefinger in this moment
he finally gets the Knights of the Vale
involved in the Wars of Westeros we
should help that was my instinct as well
our Lord has spoken they've never gotten
mixed in because Lysa was so crazy and
paranoid and that's what she got so mad
at Catelyn about for asking for her help
with so now Littlefinger just brought in
a very fresh very well-rested army that
has not lost a single soldier to any
battle lately
it's quite possible this could be the
largest army in Westeros right now
though don't quote me on that I'm not
100% sure
we only know for sure that because Jamie
tells us that the Terrell's have the
second largest but I wouldn't be
surprised if these untouched Knights of
the Vale are the largest and they're now
all under Littlefinger's control so well
played Peter speaking of Littlefinger
when we move on to marine Littlefinger
actually is the clever man that tyrion
is quoting when he defends his decision
to negotiate with the slavers as a
clever man once told we make peace with
our enemies not our friends you might
remember Littlefinger saying the same
thing to Ned Stark in season one about
the Lannisters we only make peace with
our enemies my lord that's why it's
called making peace it's interesting how
far little fingers influence reaches in
this world and just how often he's the
one behind things but I will get to that
later
so here the heads of a suppor youkai and
volantis arrive on these ships with
harpy sails and we know these are the
men who are big fans of slavery because
that sigil it's holding up chains that
represent slavery and that's why Tyrion
seven-year proposal is actually a really
smart move real quick the creators of
this show compared Terrans dilemma to
Abraham Lincoln's dilemma he had also
tried to use his negotiation skills to
end slavery and avoid a civil war but
remember Lincoln did not stop that Civil
War from happening so I gotta wonder is
Tyrion gonna suffer the same fate if not
if he somehow avoids war then have no
doubt george RR martin is saying that
tyrion would make a better president
than lincoln small thing here you might
remember this guy as the slave trader
who bought Tyrion and Jorah last season
and now is running things in his town
and Roz Dahl is the rich guy from whom
Dany declined his boats and I might be
misremembering it but I'm pretty sure
she like half Sadducees that guy in the
books by just like leaving one of her
boobs out during their whole
conversation but anyway this third guy
who's he according to the credits that's
Bela toe from volantis and we've never
seen him before but a fun fact about
that character named Bella chose the
name of another character from the books
and it does not matter at all that
they're not the same character the point
is george RR martin named
that guy after the New England Patriots
head coach Bill Belichick you see Martin
famously hates the New England Patriots
and their coach Bill Belichick he wrote
about how evil the guy is so anyway
while Martin was writing the most recent
book the Patriots had that undefeated
season until they were beaten by the
Giants in the 2007 Super Bowl so the
belly choke character in the books he
has an undefeated reign as well until
he's literally eaten by Giants that's
fun
haha point is this guy might not be to
long for this world okay now when Tyrion
has to explain this decision to the
people of marine a few interesting
things happen here first we see he's in
Daenerys his throne room but very
purposely they show him walk away from
the throne coming down the steps to
speak to these people at their own level
that's very different from Daenerys but
then he also gives them this long list
of things that he is not but I am NOT
your ruler I'm not the breaker of shades
not the unburnt and I am certainly not
the mother of giants that's the direct
opposite of Daenerys his approach she
sits above everyone else and she makes
them sit through a long list of her
titles you are in the presence of
Daenerys Stormborn of House Targaryen
queen of the Andals and the first men
Khaleesi of the great grass sea breaker
of chains and mother of dragons like
Littlefinger tyrion tells a story to
manipulate people supposedly Daenerys
has come up with this seven year plan
except she didn't and supposedly grey
worm was a big part of these
negotiations and he wasn't and Masson
day even picks up on this knack of
telling stories or telling lies by
quoting that same Littlefinger quote but
pretending it was some wise man all to
manipulate these people of murine and
get their way there's a lot more of this
strategy soon by the way if you think
I'm being harsh on Danny's style of rule
I actually don't intend to be at all
it's just a different style of rule
Daenerys Targaryen is a conqueror
through and through that's how you
define this kind of person that just
kind of takes what's in her way and
honestly I mean she is replacing it with
better systems it's not the worst thing
Tyrion is just more of the great
negotiator if you
and I think realistically that's why
these two really need to come together
if they are ever going to be these great
rulers of Westeros you have to have both
the negotiation skills and the
conquering skills it's like the mr.
Miyagi theory whatever works like you
really should avoid a fight as much as
you can and try to negotiate Judi shot
if I did not good but like Miyagi says
and any good karate kid knows if you do
have to fight well then you want to
conquer on your side you what you want
to win a thief bust tight wait
I think you actually do need to add both
of these in order to actually
successfully rule any kind of world or
country or fictional world but moving on
Daario and Jorah a joke about writing
the dragon as they hide their weapons
and did you notice how obsessed with
this knife Daario is he kisses its but
it might be because it's his lucky knife
remember this is the same knife that he
used to take down the horse of the
champion of murine considering it ends
up saving Joris life - it probably also
now his lucky knife okay so then in the
temple the doge colleen we see another
shot of Dany staring into the flame
torches that fill the room and I think I
explained the importance of her staring
into those flames enough in our last
episode breakdown do check it out though
if you want to see just how much
foreshadowing they did for the big
finale of this episode let's move on
anyway worth noting the other widows
don't trust Dany because they don't
think Dothraki should dilute their
bloodlines by breeding with outsiders
and Dany actually knows better than
anyone how dumb an idea that is the
Targaryen swerve cest with keeping their
bloodlines here through incest and it's
probably why they were so crazy that
said I actually don't know that Danny
isn't gonna end up with a Targaryen at
some point but we will cross that gross
bridge when we get to it quickly I also
want to point out how the elder Widow
tells Danny the story of Lazzarini the
young ex Khaleesi kind of looks like
Rihanna it's another example in this
episode of a character using a story to
manipulate someone into taking a certain
path in this case the story is supposed
to convince Danny that being kept in
this forced retirement home is actually
a good thing she could have had much
worse supposedly so Danny's like yeah
I'm not buying it like she knows she
probably would have just killed that
call on his sleep or something now
moving on to the dungeons kind of below
King's Landing Margaery watches this
millipede crawl up the wall and I think
this shots pretty intentional millipedes
are known for burrowing themselves deep
underground like how Marjorie's
portrayed here and despite what people
think they actually don't have a lot of
options for defense they don't sting you
instead they roll up in a tight ball and
they just try to hold on for as long as
they can that's Margaery right now
burrowed deep regularly being attacked
but just trying her best to just hold
tight until she's somehow saved from
this situation and she has been pretty
damn resilience okay let's talk about
this scene with her in the high Sparrow
that leads to the name of this episode
he starts to lecture Marjorie with the
story of his past but kind of like Danny
earlier when she's hearing a story she's
like yeah yeah I've heard this one I'm
not buying it look at the strangers
verse 25 you know the seven-pointed star
so dear Nana reads it to me
okay so book of the stranger is the
title of this episode but here's why it
has to do with what's going on in this
scene so first I'm gonna point out to
you that the high Sparrow and this story
about the shoes
yeah he's lying we've already heard a
different story for why two high Sparrow
is barefoot he told Cersei last season
that he gave his shoes away to someone
who needed that
I know shoes because I gave him away to
someone who needed them more so this
means that this story he's telling it's
just another one of these stories that
people tell in this episode to
manipulate someone into doing what they
want and the book of the stranger is
just a story from their version of the
Bible like sure there's some interesting
stuff about the fact that the book of
the stranger is basically all about
death and how death finds all men the
stranger is the Westeros version of
death sure but more importantly this is
basically how religion works in general
a bunch of stories are passed down
through generations all to just
manipulate people to behave a certain
way so it's not that the text of the
book of the stranger is terribly
important otherwise you would have heard
a lot more of it it's just a famous
example of how everyone uses parables or
stories to get what they want in this
moment it's the high Sparrow who is
trying to control her and sway her into
confessing and normally like
Littlefinger and Tyrion the high Sparrow
is actually pretty good at this
manipulation what's interesting here
though is when he's using a story and
he's speaking from the book it's not
really working because she's like yadda
yadda I've heard it boring so he tries a
different manipulative tactic that I
don't think Margery realizes is
happening she gets to see Loras it's our
second brother-sister reunion the
episode and they go back and forth about
being strong need to stage that's a
reference to their Tyrell house words of
growing strong but then Margaery says
she's got it all figured out
did either of us
- what they want that lamp they want her
to go in and help break down lawyers but
what she doesn't realize is that she is
the one being manipulated here the high
Sparrow knows Loras is already broken
and he's using him to break her at the
end she's actually the one that gives in
to Loras begging her to help him make it
stop make it stop I think this is the
very moment where Margaery gives in and
the high sparrows manipulation seems to
win her over at least I think that she
is kind of quitting her defiance right
now it is worth noting that we don't see
her again this episode so it feels like
the telling stories didn't necessarily
convince her but he's a pretty badass
manipulator and it this does seem like
it broke through so I got it wonder how
that's gonna play out for her atonement
story versus he won that Cersei has
planned for her okay now these next two
scenes contain a ton of clues that I
think might be setting up a big twist so
let's just break it all down and then
you can let me know if you think this is
gonna happen Tom and tell Cersei that
the high Sparrow told him something
something I want to tell you something
the high Sparrow told me and based on
the tears in his eyes it feels like it's
something big and I know it's semi
implied that maybe he just told him that
Marjorie's gonna have a walk of shame on
like Tuesday but we actually never hear
Tom and say that we just hear Cersei say
that and if my theory is correct we
should not trust her at all
I mean even if my theory is not correct
we should not trust her at all so I
think the high Sparrow told Tom and
something else and just before Tom and
tells Cersei what that thing is she puts
her hand over his heart and we get a
carefully designed shot that shows us
this ring that ring once belonged to
Joffrey you might remember it from his
death scene
so I think the high Sparrow actually
told Tommen who killed Joffrey the
Terrell's loris clearly has spilled
everything and that secret is known
within his family and so in this scene
that we abruptly cut away to before we
hear Tom and say the words Cersei and
Jaime suddenly have this elaborate plan
for supposedly saving Margaery from a
walk of shame and taking out the faith
militant killing the high Sparrow and
yadda yadda it's all just way too damn
tidy for me instead let's remember what
this episode is all about telling
stories who manipulate the situation so
I think instead Cersei is setting up
vengeance against the Terrell's for
having killed Joffrey and she's killing
two birds with one stone she's gonna pit
them against the faith militant whom she
also hates and my current guess is while
they're at each other's throats sir
she's gonna find a way to seize power
away from her uncle Kevin and take
control of that Lannister army and
somehow crush the Terrell's
and the faith all at once this would
also once again give her the upper hand
in King's Landing and I think this is
all being foreshadowed by that music in
the background you hear that
it's the rains of castamere the same
song we heard at the red wedding the
last time the Lannisters pulled a
deceptive trick against another house
now of course yes this is all just a
theory and it's mostly based on the fact
that we see Joffrey's ring but I think
it's also telling that something big is
coming because did you hear what pycelle
was warning Tommen about what the big
thing they must not do is I have built
with phonetics I've ever description
your grace not setting them off that's
the most important thing they can't set
the high Sparrow ah Tommen makes the
same warning you have to be careful not
to antagonize him so whatever happens I
have a strong feeling an attack on the
church is coming and even if Cersei does
have a plan I just think it's not gonna
go how anyone expects doesn't it just
feel like everyone is under estimating
the high Sparrow in this scenario like
so whoever ends up being on top and the
Marjorie's in the high Sparrow and the
Lannisters I think it's gonna be
surprised to most of them at least who
that ends up being actually this was all
predicted by the way by an old riddle
that Varys told in like season two three
great men sit in a room a king a priest
and a rich man between them stands a
common sellsword each great man bids the
sell sword kill the other two who lives
who dies bears of conclusion is that
power resides where men believe it
resides it's a trick a shadow on the
wall it's a trick it's like a shadow on
the wall
see means scarier than it is in this
coming conflict
the Lannisters represent the king the
faith militant represent the priests and
the Terrell's represent the rich man
each of them has a different kind of
power but whoever comes out on top
depends on who's the best and making it
seem like they have the most power who
can make the spookiest shadow on the
wall I would argue it might not be any
of them but I'm gonna get to that
shortly we then get 1/3 brother-sister
reunion with Fionna and Yara in Pike and
it's another one of these callbacks that
this episode keeps doing it's very
similar to the last time that Theon
returned to Pike in both times he
received a very icy welcome except the
first time he was wearing fancy clothes
and was way too cocky and now he's so
completely broken and before it was his
father Bale on who
made him feel like garbage and his time
with the sister Yara filling that exact
same role she even sits in her father's
salt throne and is just as bitter and
salty as that old man was so I gotta
admit her paranoia is fairly legit
since Dion's arrival is very
conveniently timed and she thinks it's
because he thinks he's the rightful king
of the Iron Islands now and yet another
example of telling the story to get your
way Theon tries to tell you are the
story of how Ramsay broke him but just
like Daenerys and just like Margery
Yara's like yeah I've heard this one in
fact I got a written letter about this
one and it came with a wiener in it oh
and that was also a letter from Ramsay
Bolton about a kidnap loved one which
makes the later letter yet another
callback okay so then we move on to
Winterfell where Ramsay peeled an apple
a Vulcan the sigil of the Bolton's the
flayed or peeled man
so that's Sansa and wolf fur bobbing
with the Falcon Margaery and Loras
talking about growing strong Dany and
fire in a moment it's a big episode 4
characters connecting to their family
roots I don't want to dwell on this
moment with OSHA too much because it's a
bummer but I will say that it is another
callback to another time when she tried
to seduce the current Lord of Winterfell
and I will also point out that her lie
this story about how the Starks kept her
prisoner and they made her serve them
and yada yada BS it's just another
attempt at using the story to manipulate
and Ramsay just like oh yeah I've heard
that one but also i'm ramsay so throat
stabbed oh also ramsay talks about the
stories that beyond told him I had to
work her to get him talking
but he took you'll do that's another way
to look at what the high Sparrow has
done to Loras and why I think that Lois
has told him everything including
Joffrey's murder there are a lot of ways
you can torture a person dragging them
to church is a pretty famous one moving
on from this I really hope it doesn't
mean anything that are edit smash cuts
from dying OSHA to the flayed man sigil
killing her is bad enough I really don't
want to know if he's gonna skin her too
though supposedly it is gonna happen to
somebody this season but moving on to
this scene and the letter that this
writer bring well there's this so
awkward dinner scene with tormund making
his eyes at Brienne and Edie none of it
and then the letter gets read now in the
books this is called the pink letter for
the pink wax stamped with the Bolton
sigil it's also called the bastard
letter because it's sent from one
bastard to another but the most
interesting difference about a letter in
the books there it's very unclear
exactly who sent the letter like yeah
it's implied that it was ramsay but so
many details are left vague that it
really feels like it could have been
anyone now in the show it's a little
less vague like I know we just saw a
Bolton writer deliver this letter so
you'd think well that has to come from
Ramsay Bolton but let's just pretend
that maybe writers can be paid off and
let's look at some of the other
possibilities or maybe just one other
possibility okay so first a moment ago I
showed you the last time Ramsay sent a
threatening letter it was to the
Greyjoy's and that letter had a yellow
seal not pink but okay so if it's not
Ramsay then why would someone send this
who would benefit from it well there's a
clue in the repeating chorus we hear
throughout the letter Winterfell is mine
busted come and see can we see come and
see now do you remember that scene I
asked you to remember earlier no you
don't owe doesn't doesn't matter I can
tell just show it to anyway I know come
and see
didn't that feel like a very forced in
line like he did not need to say that
and he definitely didn't need to word it
that way so yeah I'm saying what if
Littlefinger sent this letter it would
make a lot of sense actually first off
where has he been all season in the past
we've seen him jump from the Eyrie to
Winterfell to King's Landing all in a
few episodes but now he's been coming
back from Winterfell forever and we
didn't see him during any of that time
so what if he actually has been
orchestrating a plan with Lord umber to
hand Rickon over to Ramsey and then he
lets John know in this letter to force
John and his wild lanes into a battle
with Ramsay but why would he do that
good question camera because if you
remember Cersei promised she would make
Littlefinger warden of the north
if he could take Winterfell back on the
Bolton's even if you succeed name me
warden of the north so if he's
sandwhiches Winterfell between John's
army and now the army that he just
brought into the fight the Knights of
the Vale
that seems pretty doable also by the way
if he does get made warden of the north
and he's given Winterfell he will now
control three out of the Seven Kingdoms
of Westeros counting the Eyrie through
robbing the Riverlands through Harrenhal
and then potentially Winterfell that's
one way from a majority this guy's
always ten steps ahead and the fact that
we don't know what he's been up to
lately
makes me think yeah it's probably been a
lot he's probably up to so much I will
get back to Littlefinger in a second but
let's wrap up the episode okay yes so
here we are at the closing images after
wiping out all of the call leadership
and without the help of your dragons by
the way but definitely with the help of
fire Dany emerges from the flames naked
and unburnt it's another callback this
one to the iconic season 1 finale
normally I compare the episodes closing
images to the opening images of that
episode but I actually think this one is
meant to be paired with the opening
images of the last episode this time the
closing images show rebirth through fire
and last episode open with the rebirth
through ice there's is the Song of Ice
and Fire and the Ice and Fire prophecies
actually aren't the only ones being
touched on here there are at least two
others that are being referenced one
back in the house of the undying Dany
was told that she would light three
fires one for life one for death and one
for love the first fire brought life to
her dragons and this second one brought
death to her call enemies I feel like
we're probably gonna see Danny light one
more fire before this series is over
maybe for love of some kind except I
think that one is gonna be on the other
side of the Narrow Sea
but speaking of seas that's the other
prophecy that I feel like is being
touched on the Dothraki saying that Dany
recently repeated where she talks about
the Sun rising in the West and setting
in the East and I explained what that
could mean in a different breakdown well
the next part of that refers to when the
Seas go dry well Danny just became the
leader of pretty much all of the
Dothraki like based on the fact that
Khal Drogo's khalasar was like 40,000
people and there were at least seven
calls here that were just recently
defeated
I think we're easily talking about more
than a hundred thousand to three under
command right now so pretty soon when
it's time for her to take these men
across the ocean to Westeros maybe on
the ships of the Iron Islands maybe
that's gonna completely
rain this land here of Essos there's not
going to be any Dothraki left here and
what is this area where they roam called
the Dothraki sea the sea will be dry by
the way another quick reason why I think
this might be where we are eventually
headed george RR martin has based much
of this story off of real world history
and well way back in the day rome was
like the fanciest place in the world and
they just like ran the show then some
familiar stuff start to happen
there was the polytheistic religion
meaning they worshipped a bunch of gods
kind of like the gods of the seven but
then Christianity came in and it started
to really confuse people with this idea
of there being only one true God a Lord
of Light they called him that sounds
familiar right so this really
destabilized Rome and as its power
players were distracted and bickering
amongst each other around Europe and
Asia other forces grew stronger
specifically the Huns were this roving
force of nomadic warriors who were
terrifying
you might remember them from Mulan a
terrifying movie they actually even kind
of look like the Dothraki so now them
and Attila were a huge threat to Rome
however the Huns had their own enemy
that they battled with a few times they
also were scary nomadic warriors and
they were known as the Visigoths or just
the Goths different kind of goth but so
same word now at the end of the day
because of the pressures that the Huns
were putting on the Goths and after
submerging and some scaring and whatnot
it was actually the Goths who famously
sacked Rome so while it wasn't the
Dothraki looking Huns even though they
did play a huge part in it it was the
Visigoths who were the nomadic warriors
who overtook Rome and if you're
wondering what did those Goths look like
oh they were just famous for their pale
skin and very light hair so yeah I think
Danny is going to lead the Dothraki
against the armies of Westeros okay
wrapping up this breakdown and my
thoughts on Littlefinger it's really
appropriate that this episode book of
the stranger all about the stories and
tall tales that people tell in order to
manipulate others it's the same episode
that brings Littlefinger back he's the
king of that he's the best storyteller
if you will in the riddle from before I
think a little finger is the one who
would win because he's the
s/m making people perceive power from
him and he ultimately seems to have the
most influence over people I recently
reminded you guys that he's the reason
the whole game of Thrones happened
because of his plot to murder Jon Arryn
and I think that's all because george RR
martin is Littlefinger or at least
that's who he thinks he would be in this
world
Martin has stated that he thinks one
strange change from the books to the
show is that Littlefinger became pretty
in your face with his villainy in the
books Littlefinger is super well-liked
everyone thinks he's awesome but also
he's not really like a point of view
character II we don't focus on him much
and yet he's still the one that's
pulling all the strings he's the master
of the entire story he's the author of
the book he's george RR martin and this
game of thrones story is just a story
he's telling us to manipulate our
feelings Game of Thrones the novel is
the book of the stranger they're both
just telling us a story of how all men
must die okay and I'm gonna try
something new a lot of you have been
asking me about next week's episode
consistently and my thoughts on the
promos and I thought well why don't I
just watch the promo live with you here
in this video and then I'll just tell
you what I think of it as we go in the
future I don't you let me know if you
want these to be part of these breakdown
videos if not I could do it somewhere
else on my Twitter or Facebook or
something but this time here's a sneak
peek at a possible segment let's watch
the promos son did you know about Ramsay
so a good question right did he know
that Ramsay is a freaking psychopath he
is supposed to know everything about
everyone so I don't know maybe he
probably did know but I don't
he loves Sansa I don't know my point is
I think we're gonna have a little tables
turn there you can kind of see the
energy there she's got brie and her like
badass sword there she's got this like
intensity I think finally Sansa is
actually gonna be the one since prizes
like oh [ __ ] she's kind of in charge
here and I think it's gonna be very
interesting to see little fingers
reaction to that moving on it's
definitely comfortably
it's a decent behind Aria and Jachin and
he gives her poison we didn't see any of
that this story but the way I remember
we're leaving it she's been given this
new chance she can now see and it is
interesting that like it's like okay
she's really on the other side of her
training we had that badass training
sequence the other time so I feel like
this is like kind of a reset now like a
redo of like here you go here's poison
to go kill somebody do you want to be a
faceless man and that I think is a
really interesting question because like
even though she's gone through all of
this we all know that needle her sword
needle is still hiding there under some
stones feel like as long as needles
around Arya Stark is still kind of
around especially again key predicting
this is the year of the Starks uh-huh I
don't know it's it's a very interesting
way that they're posing the question now
do you want to poison people that's our
job as faceless men you sure you want to
do that so I'm curious it answer to who
makes your claim I came to salt throne
the next we get that Kingsmoot with Yara
claiming the salt throne I feel like
pretty obvious right that it's like well
you're on is standing somewhere nearby
right is he he's probably going to at
least contest that he did just kill
their king for this reason yeah that'll
be interesting
no no just meet you power but there's
still so much she done yeah okay so that
red priestess we saw her in the the
trailer for this whole season super
interesting because she's dealing with
Tyrion talking about how much they don't
know
so when I was talking with the
prophecies earlier about Daenerys and
she's there in marine now so we've got
this red priestess clearly she's meant
to kind of remind us of Melisandre but
red priestess is in general would but
Melisandre is paired with Jon Snow right
now and is treating him like a Sora hi
the princess promise clearly he's the
hero that fulfills the prophecy in
Melisandre dies and that's why she's
tied to him it's really interesting to
see one in marine this episode
specifically because like I said earlier
these were supposed to be mirrored
images of these rebirths where jon is
reborn through ice and Daenerys is
reborn through fire at the end of this
episode so red priestess and marine it
reminds me of back in seasons five the
priestess that she was like an Asian
high priestess from volantis and she was
saying Daenerys was the savior that
they've been waiting for shame Oh Kathy
no shita squeezed a Leo's peso me Zeke
leta Daria the three cookie and I
believe in the prophecy there is
something about being reborn in smoke we
just saw that from Daenerys I think is
um I would be I think this is really
very cool if this red priestess is all
like oh yeah Daenerys azor Ahai the
Prince I was promised
oh and Melisandre is like no Jon Snow
cuz that we all talk about like oh are
those two gonna end up together instead
what if they both either are the
fulfillment of the prophecy or have to
like fight to decide like who's gonna be
the fulfillment of the prophecy I don't
know but that's just excites me to see a
red priestess in Mereen just after
generics just showed like she kind of is
a superhero uh for yeah moving on
amazing okay so bran is doing his worgen
thing and the night's king can see him
and it looks like all those whites can
see him those whites look to me like the
white some hardhome so I don't think
that's like a super ancient thing he's
looking at what some people were asking
me that like oh is he just seeing you
know the beginning of of White Walkers
or something it's like maybe but this
moment feels like he's in the present
just seeing the White Walkers that are
currently around and currently coming
but really interesting something that
nobody's asking about Mira is like
Brandi you gotta wake up you gotta wake
up what's going on like at the tree
because she can't work she's not seeing
what's in his eyes so that means like
danger or something that's what I'm
absolutely the most pumped for in the
next episode it's cold at the door and
like the doorway between these worlds
and like it just it feels like an
episode that we're gonna like learn at
least more about the night king or
something like that it's also episode
five which is always like such a big
episode I'm realizing that I'm kind of
tend to ramble more in these sections
where I just watch this preview for next
episode so maybe I shouldn't put these
in this video but I'm super pumped for
next week's episode mostly based on the
white Walker scene just tag right there
at the very end I cannot wait to see it
okay some lingering questions one what
do you think of this theory about Cersei
secret plan for the Tourelles in the
faith militant knowing the way that Game
of Thrones goes these neat tidy rescue
missions always seem to end up with a
few major characters thein we'll see
what happens I just tell me what you
think about that theory to another
callback that I didn't reference is the
bear and the maiden fair where the
maiden fair was Brienne and we have a
new bear with torment are they this
shows new power couple like I yeah I'm
shipping for it but also wasn't torn
them like known for sleeping with bears
their song remind me I'm making it up I
don't know but do you think that these
two are actually gonna get together I
would love it okay and three what do you
think of Tyrians Lincolnesque compromise
I don't know if you caught this but the
Dothraki calls mentioned that the ucae
offered ten thousand horses in exchange
for Dany
that means the slavers know that Dani is
not actually in control of Marines so
they know that he was vsam so yeah maybe
war is half
and Tyrion can't help it or maybe not
maybe he's verted the whole thing what
do you think's gonna happen there it is
he that good of a negotiator did he
prevent a civil war okay that's it I'm
done with this episode's breakdown make
sure to check out all our other
breakdowns though episodes one through
three of this season I explained a lot
of the fan theories that are going
around and we're gonna probably
reference them as we go so if you still
need to understand sup a little bit
better definitely go back and check
those out and if you like this video hit
like on it but please share it
constantly that's Muffy's my request if
you can let other Game of Thrones fans
know about these videos I would love to
expand our little clique we have going
subscribe to this channel so you also
get them as they come and also we're
gonna do some more new content pretty
soon so you want that too follow us on
twitter at new rockstars to find out
when that new content is coming out
follow me on twitter at fimo you can
have full on nerdy tweets at me if you
want to have longer conversation
facebook at facebook.com slash fimo
knows this is a lot of stuff to say at
the end of the video so I'm just gonna
see you next time bye